regardez c'est parti ça aussi vous
adorez c'est les micro trottoirs de samy
c'est parti bonjour bonjour alors vous
savez comment carmaux carrément ok sympa
moi c'est totalement on chante et
enchante et aussi personnage qui dit que
25 % des français sont sexistes et vous
moi je suis plutôt poste vous en tant
que femme comment vous vous sentez dans
la société esprit sommes votre cassette
vous et moi je pense j'espère sonntag
c'est un job zone qu'est ce que tu
penses de l'égalité des sexes salles de
cours c'est là la taille des décisions
en fait ça fait pas la même taille pour
les pour certains bon c'est didier qui
fait sens et intérim restait assez se
donnait le plaisir c'est tout dans
l'égalité des sexes et avec ce qu'ils
ont pensé moi parce qu'en fait il ya des
gens qui n'ont pas la même taille du
pénis et d'autre oui et c'est un peu
chiant pour certains non mais bon très
bien m'a écouté très bonne journée
madame quand on fait un peu plus
confiance aux femmes sur des postes à
responsabilités après bon le salaire
s'assure toujours pas c'est sympa trop
déjà pas mal ce qu'on vous donne
oui merci c'est gentil
donc qu'est ce que tu penses toi de
l'égalité hommes femmes pour l'égalité
et à risque excuse moi j'essaie par
rapport la paix coup à toi si tu peux
continuer à répondre pour les gt gt
rythme je vais jetter c'est important
parce que le travail et des salaires
aujourd'hui les femmes elles sont
beaucoup de droits par rapport à des
hommes parce que tout ça parce qu'elles
ont dit mme michon ses lauriers
c'est pour ça que tu penses que si les
hommes les avaient des nichons ça
changerait je pense que oui qui a
peut-être est en position s'il faut la
respecter au shit mais on n'est pas
encore dans l'égalité que j'aimerais
déjà un petit peu derrière ou pas
toujours voir sa progression n'est pas
encore maintenant dans l'égalité
parfaite par exemple vous arrivez à vous
habiller comme vous voulez sans doute
aussi fait dans la rue boyer s'est pas
embêtant des fois qu'on investisse dans
la rue quand vous mettez une petite mini
jupe par exemple moi je vais pas
m'habiller embellie jeu souvenez vous un
jour je sais pas maintenant
ouais c'est un choix ouais je pense que
si tout on y met du sien au livre est
jetée fait courte ou de longue comme tu
veux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]